Trascrizione: Martina Tortorici
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
Io vorrei partire con una domanda.
Così, per provare anche un po’
a svegliarci dopo il pranzo.
Se la scienza lo permettesse,
voi quanti anni vorreste vivere?
Quanto lunga dovrebbe essere
secondo voi la vostra vita?
Pensateci un attimo.
Potete anche rispondermi, se volete.
70 anni, 80, 100, 1000, magari di più?
Non so... Come?
120 precisi. Ok, rispettabili.
Non so se vi siete posti mai
questa domanda.
Io me la sono fatta qualche volta
e la risposta
che personalmente mi sono dato
è che sinceramente la domanda
non mi interessa molto.
Mi dispiace per i 120 anni,
però ritengo che non sia questa
la domanda da porsi,
che non sia prioritario, o meglio...
perché la domanda
che veramente secondo me è rilevante,
importante da affrontare, a cui rispondere
è come potrei, come potremmo,
avere una qualità della vita ottimale,
quindi essere in piena salute,
al massimo delle nostre funzioni
fino all’ultimo giorno,
all’ultimo minuto della nostra vita.
Questo secondo me è una priorità,
e penso quindi di conseguenza
che l’umanità deve concentrarsi
sulle sfide giuste.
Quindi, se posso permettermi anche
di ricollegarmi ai talk di stamattina,
l’umanità deve affrontare il cambiamento
climatico subito perché urgentissimo.
Deve trovare cure per malattie genetiche
che colpiscono bambini,
milioni di bambini,
che sono terribili.
Subito dopo però, o meglio ancora,
in parallelo a questo,
deve, secondo me, provare
a sviluppare tecnologie
che aumentino il più possibile
la qualità della vita delle persone
e non che la allunghino.
Quindi noi non abbiamo secondo me
bisogno di vivere 150... 120 magari sì,
però non 150 anni, 200 anni;
non è questo che ci serve.
Ci serve viverli al meglio.
La bioingeneria si occupa di questo.
Quindi io, insieme a voi,
vorrei capire un po’ come siamo messi,
a che punto siamo con queste tecnologie,
e provare anche a capire
qual è la prospettiva da qui al 2050.
Partirei dal diabete come primo esempio.
Più di 100 anni fa,
chi si ammalava di diabete,
tipicamente bambini e adolescenti,
purtroppo aveva
un’aspettativa di vita ridottissima
di pochi giorni, di poche settimane,
perché non c’era una cura.
Poi 100 anni fa, esattamente 100 anni fa,
fu scoperta l’insulina
e questo ormone, questa invenzione
ha salvato la vita di milioni di persone.
L’aspettativa di vita di fatto
oggi per i pazienti diabetici
è paragonabile a quella
dei soggetti non diabetici.
Quindi potreste pensare che il problema
è risolto, non c’è più da fare niente.
Già 100 anni fa era stato risolto.
Ma non è così,
perché questo allungamento
dell’aspettativa di vita ha un costo
e questo costo è la necessità
di aderire costantemente a una terapia
tutti i giorni senza eccezioni.
Quindi tutti i giorni senza eccezioni,
un paziente diabetico
deve bucarsi un dito,
far uscire una goccia di sangue,
misurare il livello di glucosio nel sangue
e poi iniettarsi una certa
precisa quantità di insulina,
tipicamente con punture nella pancia
con dosatori o cose del genere.
Capite bene che si può far meglio,
cioè la tecnologia può migliorare
la qualità di vita di queste persone
e bisogna puntare a questo.
Ora, qual è l’ottimo?
Qual è il sogno di un bioingegnere
in questo campo?
Il sogno sarebbe di avere
diciamo degli omini miniaturizzati,
immaginiamoceli così,
che stiano all’interno del corpo,
che facciano tutto loro,
che risolvano il problema,
che facciano quello che fa
l’organo naturale sano
e che noi non ce ne accorgiamo neanche.
Quindi che non interferiscano
in nessun modo con la nostra vita.
Vediamo un po’
a che punto siamo con questi omini?
Negli anni ’70
sono stati introdotti per la prima volta
i cosiddetti pancreas artificiali.
Erano delle macchine,
come quella che vedete qua nell’immagine.
Questa fu la prima,
cosiddetto “biostator” nel ’77,
che automaticamente, da sole,
misuravano la glicemia
e iniettavano l’insulina
nel corpo del paziente.
Quindi facevano le azioni che dicevo prima
quindi liberavano in qualche modo
il paziente dal doverle fare.
Questo sistema funzionava,
funzionava anche abbastanza bene,
però aveva un piccolo difettuccio
che magari potete intuire anche voi:
è più grande del paziente stesso,
quindi altro che miniaturizzato,
era un oggetto che era lontanissimo
dall’essere portabile e di fatto usabile.
Però sono passati vari decenni.
Oggi siamo nel 2021
e la bioingegneria ha fatto
dei passi avanti notevoli.
Oggi i pancreas artificiali
sono fatti così.
Sono costituiti da elementi
come questa pompa peristaltica
che è lei, di fatto,
con un’intelligenza a bordo
che inietta insulina automaticamente
tramite un tubicino,
un cateterino transcutaneo
che attraversa la pelle del paziente
e rilascia l’insulina sottopancia.
Quindi finalmente, nel 2021,
problema risolto.
Possiamo dire che abbiamo ripristinato
la qualità della vita al cento per cento.
In parte sì,
ma siamo lontani dall’avere
una soluzione veramente ottimale
per i pazienti diabetici.
Perché?
Perché questo cateterino transcutaneo
ogni tanto si infetta,
quindi va sostituito periodicamente
con dei piccoli interventi.
Soprattutto questi sistemi
sono tutti esterni,
quindi un paziente deve badare
continuamente, costantemente
a questi sistemi,
deve starci attento.
Non può fare, ad esempio, degli sport.
Non può fare nuoto,
non può fare varie cose,
in modo almeno spensierato.
E poi c’è una questione estetica.
Molti ragazzi e ragazze non accettano
di buon grado sistemi del genere,
anche in altri campi,
perché di fatto si vedono all’esterno
e non sono ben accettati.
Quindi torniamo un attimo ai nostri omini.
L’ottimo sarebbe avere qualcosa
che sparisce completamente
all’interno del corpo
e non ce ne accorgiamo neanche,
che fa dimenticare al paziente
la propria patologia.
Questo è il sogno.
Però, appunto, è un sogno?
È un’utopia?
È fantascienza?
Allora, diciamo così:
Il problema qua è
che se io ho un oggetto impiantato,
un dispositivo che contiene insulina,
l’insulina abbiamo detto è
da 100 anni il farmaco
che usiamo per contrastare il diabete,
per ricaricare questo serbatoio
quando l’insulina finisce,
perché dopo un po’ finisce,
come si fa se è impiantato?
Non è che si può fare un intervento
chirurgico ogni due mesi, no?
Allora noi ci siamo inventati
questa cosa un po’ folle,
cioè una capsulina piena di insulina
e in qualche modo intelligente
che il paziente può inghiottire o ingerire
una volta alla settimana,
una volta ogni due settimane,
e lei da sola, in modo autonomo, naviga
attraverso il tratto gastro-intestinale,
viene riconosciuta
dal dispositivo impiantato,
che fa tutto da solo,
la cattura e in qualche modo
trasferisce l’insulina dalla capsula
al serbatoio impiantato, ricaricandolo
e poi ovviamente rilasciando la capsula,
che viene poi espulsa.
Potete immaginarvi, insomma,
come succede questo, no? Ok.
Io sono molto ottimista
perché questo non è solo un’idea,
questo è un prototipo
che abbiamo sviluppato
e abbiamo anche dimostrato che funziona
e siamo nel 2021.
Quindi c’è margine nei prossimi decenni
sicuramente per far diventare
questo un prodotto
che può aiutare
a migliorare la qualità della vita
di milioni di pazienti e di persone.
Ma io sono sicuro
che nei prossimi 30 anni
la bioingegneria svilupperà
soluzioni analoghe,
magari ancora più ambiziose
per una serie di altri organi.
Sto parlando di reni, fegato, cuore,
per i quali, attualmente,
l’unica soluzione è il trapianto.
Quindi pensate
a quante prospettive ci sono.
Oltre al diabete, però,
e a patologie simili,
è opportuno anche concentrarsi,
secondo me,
su patologie che insorgono
in un’età più avanzata.
Per esempio l’osteoartrite.
L’osteoartrite è una malattia
che insorge, appunto,
tipicamente sopra i 50-60 anni
e comporta una forte infiammazione
e degenerazione della cartilagine.
La cartilagine è un tessuto
che fa funzionare al meglio
le nostre articolazioni.
Quindi chi soffre di osteoartrite,
di fatto, soffre di una ridotta mobilità,
dolore e di una qualità
di vita notevolmente ridotta.
Per darvi un’idea di quanto
è diffusa questa patologia,
pensate che metà persone
sopra i 60 anni nel mondo, metà!
La metà della popolazione
soffre di osteoartrite.
Quindi tantissime.
Sopra gli 80 anni tutte,
pressoché tutte le persone
soffrono di una forma di artrosi
che ne limita la mobilità
e la qualità della vita.
È un problema che ha un impatto enorme
nella nostra società,
che fra l’altro
sta invecchiando rapidamente.
In questo campo una tecnologia
che avrebbe un potenziale enorme
è quella delle cellule staminali.
Cosa sono le cellule staminali?
Le cellule staminali sono...
Voi tutti sapete che noi nel nostro corpo
abbiamo miliardi
di cellule molto specializzate,
ad esempio i neuroni nel cervello
elaborano informazioni
e controllano altri organi e tessuti.
Gli epatociti nel fegato, invece, sono
delle specie di centrali chimiche
che producono sostanze utili
per il metabolismo
e così via.
Le cellule staminali, invece,
non sono specializzate,
ma tutti noi le abbiamo.
Abbiamo un certo numero
di cellule staminali
che stanno lì,
non hanno un compito specifico.
Però proprio perché
non hanno un compito specifico
hanno il potenziale di rigenerare,
di diventare qualsiasi cellula
o tessuto del nostro corpo.
Quindi hanno anche
il potenziale di rigenerarlo,
se questi tessuti sono soggetti
a un trauma
o a una degenerazione.
Detta così sembra un po’ facile
e in effetti non lo è.
Non è assolutamente così semplice.
Queste cellule non lo fanno
automaticamente da sole
e la bioingegneria riesce
a ingegnerizzare,
quindi a far capire a queste staminali
cosa devono diventare,
solo in un numero
molto piccolo di tessuti.
Per esempio la pelle.
Però per la cartilagine,
per esempio, non ci riusciamo.
Non sappiamo quali sono
le istruzioni giuste da dare alle cellule,
come se mancasse loro
il libretto di istruzioni
per diventare tessuto cartilagineo nuovo
e noi stiamo cercando di capire
qual è il libretto di istruzioni.
Come si fa?
È complicato.
Però si può fare.
Stiamo studiando dei nanomateriali,
quindi degli omini ancora
più miniaturizzati di quelli di prima,
addirittura alla nanoscala,
che insieme a dei materiali intelligenti
possono essere stampati,
quindi rilasciati in modo controllato
all’interno dell’articolazione
mediante degli opportuni
strumenti chirurgici
e poi solidificati in situ,
cioè nei punti in cui serve,
grazie a uno stimolo luminoso.
Quindi usando semplicemente la luce
a una certa lunghezza d’onda,
questi materiali intelligenti
possono essere “freezati”,
bloccati, stabilizzati
nel punto in cui serve una terapia,
cioè nei punti
in cui la cartilagine è degradata.
Poi lo stimolo, il libretto di istruzioni
di cui parlavamo prima,
è dato da una specie di ginocchiera
che produce ultrasuoni.
Gli ultrasuoni sono gli stessi ultrasuoni
che sicuramente tutti voi conoscete
che si usano per le ecografie,
ma usati in un modo un po’ diverso.
Gli ultrasuoni,
se interagiscono con questo
materiale intelligente di cui ho parlato,
riescono a fornire gli stimoli giusti
alle staminali
per farle diventare cartilagine.
E anche qui,
anche in questo caso
dal video abbiamo visto
che i risultati di laboratorio ci dicono
che questo succede davvero,
che è un metodo efficace di differenziare
le staminali in cartilagine.
Quindi di nuovo io sono molto ottimista
perché, ripeto, siamo nel 2021
e pensate quindi
a quali meravigliose frontiere
la bioingegneria ha di fronte
e può esplorare.
Se pensate che la qualità della vita,
quello di cui ho parlato,
non sia una priorità,
per voi, almeno,
perché molti di voi sono giovanissimi,
ok... liberi di pensarlo.
Però tenete presente
che l’età media della popolazione italiana
oggi è di 47 anni,
l’età media di tutta la popolazione.
Nel 2050 l’età media sarà di 54 anni,
quindi 7 anni di più.
Quindi in solo 30 anni
noi alzeremo l’asticella dell’età media,
dell’aspettativa di vita, di ben 7 anni
e questo sarà possibile
grazie ai progressi della medicina.
Però, come dicevo, non ci possiamo
e non ci dobbiamo accontentare di questo
perché un po’ tutti noi
dovremo fare i conti
con come vivremo la seconda parte
della nostra vita.
E poi pensate
a quanto sarebbe bello un mondo
in cui nessun anziano avesse pensieri,
problemi nell’alzarsi da una sedia
e abbracciare il proprio nipote
e giocare con lui.
Infine, dopo questo discorso variegato
sulle frontiere della bioingegneria,
alcuni, altri, di voi potrebbero pensare:
va bene, ok, mi hai convinto, tutto bello.
Bravi! Viva la scienza!
Però io cosa posso fare,
oltre ad ascoltare?
Questo vale un po’ forse
per tutti gli argomenti.
Oltre a tifare per la scienza,
cosa potrei fare io,
se non faccio scienza?
Secondo me, personalmente, potete fare
almeno due cose molto pratiche.
La prima è prendere le distanze
in modo netto
da chiunque proponga
soluzioni magiche, scorciatoie,
soluzioni a problemi,
specialmente in ambito sanitario,
che non si basano
su evidenze scientifiche.
Qui ogni riferimento ai no-vax
è puramente non casuale.
La seconda cosa pratica,
molto pratica, che potete fare
è far sì che, fare in modo
che tutte le persone del pianeta
possano accedere a queste tecnologie.
Questo perché la bioingegneria,
un po’ come tutte le tecnologie,
dovrebbe essere un bene di tutti.
Quindi se tutti accederanno
o solo una piccola parte della popolazione
accederà a queste innovazioni,
ancora non è scritto.
Questo ovviamente non dipende
da noi scienziati,
se accadrà o meno,
dipende dalle scelte politiche
degli Stati occidentali dei prossimi anni.
Ora però, noi siamo gli Stati occidentali.
Voi lo siete
e quindi fate sentire la vostra voce
e sottolineate l’importanza
della ricerca, ovviamente,
ma soprattutto sottolineate l’importanza
che ci sia un’ampia accessibilità
a queste tecnologie,
in modo che le risorse e le tecnologie
siano distribuite in modo equo
nei prossimi anni.
Se tutti insieme lavoreremo
verso questo obiettivo
sono sicurissimo che il mondo nel 2050
sarà un posto molto,
molto migliore di quello di oggi.
Grazie.